okay scene one take two creators from  around the world while we are all social  distancing why don't we have some fun  action we challenge you to make a 60  second short film about well anything  really any style any genre fear horror  action sci-fi we've been documentary and  you could shoot it on whatever you want  big cameras small cameras really small  cameras you can even animate it the  possibilities are endless only rule is  you need to do it from inside your  building so let's get those creative  juices flowing then we'll pick our  favorites and those films we featured on  great big story good luck  wash your hands and happy filmmaking  you  [Music]